foreign
welcome to this interesting video on
blockchain in-depth tutorial blockchain
is a groundbreaking technology that
enables anyone to track transactions on
a distributed digital Ledger without a
central Authority
so this video will explore various
important aspects of blockchain and the
related Concepts in depth but before
diving deep into its concept we will
first explore the basics starting with
what blockchain is features of
blockchain like public distributed
Ledger encryption proof of work mining
smart contracts and its use cases that
will make your base even more stronger
then we will dive down deeper into its
internal Concepts and learn about the
candidate block Byzantine fault
tolerance the addition of two blocks at
the same time Forks like soft work and
at hard Forks areas where blockchain is
used what is the future of blockchain
and then we will have a peek at
blockchain jobs available
following these we will understand why
we need blockchain and Its Real World
applications in healthcare government
blockchain and kyc trade Finance
mortgage industry loan Management
blockchain in Estonia energy markets
block media
travel supply chain and network security
like Korea Telecom
then we will see how to become a
blockchain developer the salary offered
to them and companies hiring blockchain
developers to boost your confidence
by the end of this video I can assure
you that all your blockchain related
Concepts will have been cleared
for this training with me I have
experienced specialist Sam and Rahul
together we'll walk you through the
different crucial blockchain Keynotes
and Concepts so let's start with an
exciting video on blockchain in-depth
tutorial but before we begin make sure
to subscribe to our YouTube channel and
hit the Bell icon to never miss an
update from Simply learn
ever wonder if there's an easier way to
complete transactions without having to
deal with online wallets Banks and
third-party applications well it's
possible thanks to blockchain here's
everything you need to know about
blockchain imagine four friends Jack Ted
Sam and Phil meet up for dinner after
they're done Jack pays the bill and all
of them decide to split the expense
amongst each other now on the next day
when Phil sends his share to Jack via
online money transfer the transaction
goes through without a hitch then Ted
and Sam send their respective shares to
Jack but their transactions don't go
through the failed transactions cites
some issues at the bank that's when Jack
comes to know about the many ways a bank
transaction could fail it could be due
to technical issues at the bank one of
their accounts were hacked daily
transfer limits being exceeded and
sometimes additional charges like
transfer charges associated with
transferring money to solve these
problems the concept of cryptocurrency
came into existence cryptocurrencies are
a form of digital or virtual currency
that run on a technology known as
blockchain thanks to blockchain
cryptocurrencies are immune to
counterfeiting don't require a central
Authority and are protected by strong
and complex encryption algorithms and in
a market of more than thousands of
cryptocurrencies like Litecoin ethereum
Z cash and so on one reign supreme
Bitcoin now let's go back to our
previous example and have Phil Ted and
Sam Send Jack two Bitcoins each as their
contribution to the previous night's
dinner let's assume Phil Ted and Sam
have three Bitcoins in reserve while
Jack has five first Phil sends two
Bitcoins to jack a record is created in
the form of a block the transaction
details between them is permanently
inscribed in this block This Record also
holds the number of Bitcoins each of the
friends own so after after Phil's
transaction Jack has seven Bitcoins
while Phil has won following this Sam
and Ted send two Bitcoins to jack a new
block is created for each of these
transactions these blocks hold the
transaction details as well as how many
Bitcoins Sam Ted and Jack have in
reserve these blocks are linked to each
other as each of them takes reference
from the previous one for the number of
Bitcoins each brand owns this chain of
Records or blocks is called a ledger and
this Ledger is shared among all the
friends which acts as a public
distributed Ledger this forms the basis
of blockchain so what happens when Phil
has only one Bitcoin left and he tries
to send two more Bitcoins to Jack the
transaction will not go through this is
because all his friends have copies of
The Ledger and it's clear that Phil has
only one Bitcoin left his friends will
flag this transaction as invalid a
hacker will not be able to alter the
data in the blockchain because each user
has a copy of The Ledger the data within
the blocks are encrypted by complex
algorithms all of this is made possible
with the help of blockchain Technology
blockchain can be described as a
collection of Records linked with each
other strongly resistant to alteration
and protected using cryptography now
let's have a closer look at the Bitcoin
transaction between Jack and Phil and
find out how it works every user in the
Bitcoin network has two keys a public
key and a private key the public key is
an address that everyone in the network
knows of like an email address of a user
the private key is a unique address that
only the user has knowledge of something
like a password first bill passes the
number of Bitcoins he wants to send to
Jack along with his and Jack's unique
wallet address through a hashing
algorithm all of this is part of the
transaction details these details are
incred scripted using encryption
algorithms and using Phil's unique
private key this is done to digitally
sign the transaction and to indicate
that the transactions came from fill
this output is now transmitted across
the world using Jack's public key with
this the message or transaction can be
decrypted only by Jack's private key
which only Jack has knowledge of
different cryptocurrencies use different
hashing algorithms while Bitcoin uses
the sha-256 algorithm ethereum which is
also a famous cryptocurrency uses one
known as ethash this transaction and
several other similar ones are taking
place all around the world these
transactions are validated and then
added block by block the people who
validate these blocks are called miners
for a block to be validated and added to
a blockchain miners need to solve a
complex mathematical problem The Miner
who solves this first adds the block to
the block chain and is rewarded with
12.5 Bitcoins the process of solving the
complex mathematical problem is called
proof of work and the process of adding
a block to the blockchain is called
mining with this Phil and Jack's wallets
are updated just like every person in
the network who has completed a
transaction now that you know about
blockchain and its important Concepts
time for a small quiz what is the
concept of blockchain that ensures data
cannot be altered by any of the users
within the network a public distributed
Ledger B proof of work
C proof of stake D hash encryption let
us know what you think is the right
answer in the comments below three lucky
winners will get Amazon gift vouchers
details are mentioned in the description
below let's have a look at how Walmart
uses blockchain to provide its customers
with better service Walmart was facing
problems in delivering quality products
to its customers they were facing a high
return rate and large amounts of refunds
due to their products bad quality they
were unable to determine the point of
failure in the supply chain which
started from Farm to storage to
transportation to processing all the way
to the customer then Walmart adopted
blockchain technology with blockchain
the quality of the goods at each step
was permanently inscribed within a block
for example when a customer Flags a
product as damaged it can be correctly
identified where the product got damaged
in the entire supply chain thus helping
Walmart to identify by the problem areas
and fixing them and this is just one of
several ways blockchain is used in real
life applications can you think of any
others let us know in the comments down
below that's all for now hello everyone
and welcome to the session of blockchain
tutorial part one my name is saurabh and
I'm part of the simply learn team so
let's get started and understand what's
in it for us today so let's take a
hypothesis in our city not so far away
somebody was up to something bad so
there's a hacker who hates Bank who
wants to steal the money of all the
people lying in the bank now here's why
I hate them even more what are the
nuances and the problem areas of the
banking system the banking system has
higher transactional and international
transfer costs a lot of documentation is
required for setting up of an account
for opening an account and onboarding a
customer and the banking system is not
always accessible it's not 24x7 it's
closed on banking holidays and it has
other limitations also like transfer
limits in a day and you know you can't
transfer x amount within a stipulated
time now banks in such an ecosystem acts
as a center point of failure it is a
centralized based system which is prone
to failure from a centralized point of
view so if the bank fails all the
transactions will come to an halt which
are dependent on the bank now let's see
what happens if the hacker is able to
get into the banking system and hacks
the bank all the investors or the people
associated with the bank the information
associated with them will get corrupted
will get jeopardized and it can lead to
huge losses to the bank and to the
individuals and all this can happen with
a click of a button it's as simple as
that so once a hacker has access to the
system he can manipulate the system
compromise the information share it with
the parties which are not supposed to
have that information and lot can go
wrong though the hackers can be caught
right it is possible through cyber
security and various means but once the
information is compromised it is very
difficult to roll that back and that's
why we need more secure systems and
systems which are not dependent on a
centralized Authority which work in a
more decentralized fashion whereby
making it hack proof plus lowering the
transaction cost also now this incident
of course will catch the bank manager's
attention now he will go to his advisors
and want to make sure this does not
happen again so the technology com
people the advisors will make sure that
this does not happen but what is the
remedy so the remedy is setting up a
blockhead now of course the manager
who's looking into the banking functions
might not be aware of the technology and
what benefits blockchain bring onto the
table in order to prevent such an
incident so that's what we are here for
we will learn before we go and
understand what can blockchain actually
G for us so we will understand today
what is blockchain the Bitcoin story the
features of blockchain like public
distributed Ledger the hashing
encryption the proof of work consensus
algorithm and the concept of Mining and
then we will cover up a use case where
how blockchain can be used for banking
operations now what is blockchain
blockchain is a list of Records called
blocks which stores data publicly and in
a chronological order and the entire
information is persisted using
cryptography it is secured using
cryptography so cryptography ensures
that the privacy of the user is
maintained and data cannot be altered
information on a blockchain network is
not controlled by a centralized
Authority for unlike modern financial
institutions nobody controls the data
within a blockchain the data is
maintained by the participants of the
network and they are the Democratic
Authority in order to approve any
transaction which can happen on a
blockchain network access to anyone on
the network so a typical blockchain
network is a public blockchain so as
long as you have access to the network
you have access to the data within the
blockchain if you are a participant on
the blockchain network you will have the
same copy of The Ledger which all other
participants have so therefore everyone
every participant on the network has the
same copy of the data so everyone in the
network has a copy of the blockchain
data which is used for ensuring that
data remains untempered so even if one
node or data on one particular
participant computer gets corrupted the
other participants will come to know
immediately that this particular
instance or node has gone corrupted and
they will Rectify it as soon as possible
so basically the question is is this the
same technology that Bitcoin works on
and the answer is yes Bitcoin could not
have been possible without blockchain so
we will understand how Bitcoin adopted
blockchain in order to reach to its
Journey today so Bitcoin was introduced
in 2009 by someone or a group of people
known as Satoshi nakomoto it aimed to
solve the problem faced by Fiat
currencies with the help of blockchain
Technology now as of today in 2018 there
are more than 1600 cryptocurrencies that
follow the concepts of Bitcoin and
blockchain for example the other popular
cryptocurrencies are like ethereum
Litecoin Dash Ripple and many more now
let me explain how a Bitcoin transaction
works the sender transmits the
transaction details worldwide basically
whenever a sender has to do a
transaction he has to send Bitcoins to a
receiver he will submit the transaction
on the public blockchain network of
Bitcoin and transmit it now verification
to authenticate users it is done by the
miners around the world so basically
there are specific participants in the
Bitcoin Network which are called as
miners whose job is to verify the
authenticity of the sender and the
receiver and also validate whether the
sender has the right amount of balance
for the Bitcoin which he is trying to
send to the receiver and ensuring that
the sanity of the underlying blockchain
Network to the Bitcoin remains correct
and not get corrupted so once the miner
has authenticated the transaction
verified all the parameters the
transaction is added to a block and then
that block is made part of the main
blockchain once the block is added to
the blockchain the money the
transactions which were associated in
the block then gets executed money is
deducted from the sender's wallet and is
added to the receiver wallet thereby
once the transaction is completed the
block is added and The Ledger across all
the nodes are updated each and every
participant Ledger copy is updated with
that particular block which has been
added in the blockchain so therefore all
the participants have the same copy of
the information now so what makes
blockchain special now these are the the
special four features of blockchain
which we're going to talk about in
detail it is a public distributed Ledger
it works using a hashing encryption each
and every block has a hash value which
is the digital signature of the block
all the transactions are approved and
verified on the blockchain network using
proof of work consensus algorithm and
the blockchain network utilizes the
resources of the miners who are there to
validate the transaction and the miners
in lieu of putting your investing in the
resources and validating the
transactions get rewards in terms of
Bitcoin and that process is called
mining now public distributed ledger so
let's imagine four friends sharing a
particular document amongst each other
correct now if there was only a single
copy of that document and one of them
altered the data it may go unnoticed
however the outcome would be different
if each one of them had a copy of the
data so therefore 4 if each and every
participant has the same copy of the
data even if one of them change the data
the others would find that the data does
not match with their own blockchain
Works in a similar fashion the data
within a blockchain is accessible to
everyone so with this as long as you are
part of the network you could access the
entire history of transactions that have
taken place since the blockchain was
created since Inception and the first
block in any blockchain is called the
Genesis block so from the Genesis block
to the current block you will have the
access to the entire chain any additions
to blockchain have to be approved by the
participant users in the blockchain
network so a majority of the members
within the network have to approve of
any additions to the blockchain this is
the public part of The Ledger and this
is important because any additions made
to the blockchain are permanent and are
immutable so immutable transactions are
the transactions which can cannot be
altered once registered they cannot be
modified and are available for audit and
verification 24x7 so this means that
each and every detail is recorded and
any alterations can be detected by
verifying it against everyone's personal
version of the blockchain so if
someone's tried to modify a data on a
block on a particular node then the
other ledgers which are having the same
information will come to know that
someone has modified data on a one
particular node and they will try to
rectify it and the fourth property no
Central Authority is controlling the
working of this blockchain network it is
a decentralized network so this is where
being decentralized helps everyone has a
copy of the blockchain which means there
is no central point of failure there is
a single source of truth even if things
go wrong the data can be recovered if
one node goes wrong the data can be
recovered from other nodes but what
about security how is privacy maintained
if everything is so public and here
hashing encryptions comes into picture
it takes care of that so now we will
talk about the second feature which is
hashing encryption but to understand
hashing encryption we need to understand
the contents what are the contents of a
block so a block in a blockchain is like
a container that holds aggregated
transactions it contains certain set of
transactions so we will see what all
things construct a particular block so a
block has two parts it has a header and
it has the second part is the
transaction details it is the set of
transactions which are aggregated in
this block now the header has following
set of attributes it has the block
version number it has the hash of the
previous block to which it is linked the
current timestamp the timestamp at which
the block was verified the nonce we will
see what is the attribute what is the
meaning of nons and Target value now the
transaction details are nothing but the
example which we talked about earlier it
is the transaction which the sender and
receiver are sharing the sender is
trying to send certain amount of Bitcoin
from his account to the receiver's
account now it is represented in the
form of a 256 bit hash value in the
header called as Merkel root or the hash
root so basically the Merkel root is the
hash of all the transactions structured
in a Merkel tree called binary tree it's
a kind of a binary tree and the hash
value of the root node of the Merkel
tree is called the Merkel root hash so
the transaction details of a block are
contained in the header in a hex value
known as Merkel root the Merkel root can
be calculated in this way so basically
the list of transaction each transaction
is passed through a hashing algorithm
then all the hashes of the transactions
are paired and then again passed through
another hashing algorithm until only one
value remains and which will be the root
now let me tell you how a hash function
Works blockchain utilizes a hash
function to perform cryptography data
from a data set of random size is sent
as input to a hashing function to get an
encrypted value of fixed size and that
is the feature of any hashing function
so some unique properties of hashing
function are these are deterministic the
same input will always produce the same
hash output small changes in the data
can drastically change the output
basically any small things to the input
produces an output that's drastically
different from its previous obtained
outputs it can be computed easily the
output values can be obtained without a
whole lot of calculation and hashing
functions are one-way functions
basically you won't be able to determine
the input based on the output value so
you can't do the reverse calculation now
let's go back to our block we were
talking about earlier so as we were
discussing what are the features in the
header the the previous hash is the
resultant hash of the previous Block in
the blockchain and this is the way two
blocks are linked together now
transaction details these are used to
provide details about the sender
receiver and how much money they want to
exchange between them and this is a list
of transactions and they are structured
in a Merkel tree and the hash of the
Merkel root is put in the header non is
a value that is varied to create a
unique hash address of the block which
should be less than the target hash
value so this is the structure of the
header it has a block version number
basically the sequence number of the
block it has the hash of the previous
block the timestamp when the blog post
mined and verified the nonce value the
header is then this entire header is
then passed through a hashing algorithm
in the case of a Bitcoin Network it is
sha256 and a hash value is generated and
now this hash value becomes the hash
value of the block now this value is a
256 bit value that is used to uniquely
identify the particular block so sha-256
ensures that alterations to data can be
easily detected so for example consider
these two blocks in the blockchain they
have a similar structure and definitely
different hash values now if someone
Alters the transaction details in the
first block the corresponding hash value
of the block would change too now the
values of hash value of the first block
and the previous hash value of the other
block will not match basically the block
subsequent to the Hacked block will get
dealing now this will raise an alarm
among the users informing them that data
alteration has taken place the users
will then be able to flag the block so
the alteration can be easily identified
and rectified immediately to ensure
security blockchain also include digital
signatures these ensure that the mess
message come from the right identity
right person and that the message is not
tampered with users are provided their
own private and public key so whenever a
user onboard a public blockchain he is
provided a pair of public and private
key now private key is used by the user
to control his her own account this is
kept as a secret by the user so
basically it says like his own password
and public key public key is used to
identify the user on the network this is
shared by the user along with the
transaction on the network for others to
verify so these are the steps involved
in creating and authenticating a digital
signature so at the center side the
message to be transmitted is passed
through the hashing algorithm in in this
case of Bitcoin it is SSH 256 and the
hash is generated plus the private key
is used to generate a digital signature
now this output is passed through a
signature algorithm along with the
user's private key to create a digital
signature now during the transmission
the user's message their digital
fingerprint which was generated in the
previous step plus the public key are
transmitted across the network so these
three things are published on the
network for the validators for the
miners to use and verify the
authenticity of the sender now at the
receiver's end first the message is
passed through a hashing algorithm now
at the same time the sender's public key
and his or her digital signature are
passed through a very fiction algorithm
now both the functions will generate a
hash if both the hashes are compared and
if they match then the transaction and
the identity of the sender is approved
otherwise it is rejected so basically
this is the process by comparing the
hash values to authenticate the identity
of the sender now what about the people
who verify these transactions and how do
they actually do it so remember that one
field in the block header called norms
that becomes very important in order to
verify the transaction so now we will
talk about the third feature which is
the proof of work consensus algorithm so
proof of work involves people around the
world the participants in the network
called miners competing to be the first
one to add a block to the blockchain and
in lieu of this they will be rewarded
there are competing miners around the
world they are trying to solve a
mathematical puzzle to be the first one
to be rewarded and to add a block to the
blockchain so this is the reward so
thereby they invest in the computing
power they invest in the resources in
order to mine and validate a transaction
to get that reward now what is the
mathematical puzzle so basically they
need to find a hash value that satisfies
certain predefined conditions now in
order to find the hash value they will
use Norms so this target hash value is
decided months in advance for everyone
lock the miners keep variating the nonce
value to find out an output that falls
within the target requirement so they
keep on generating a hash value using
the nons and if it is less than the
target the hash value is accepted and if
it is greater then the hash values
rejected the miners effort is not
considered valid now a minor transmits
across the world that he has found a
nonce that satisfies the target
requirement as soon as you find it and
thanks to the hashing algorithm use this
claim can be easily verified by others
so basically the proof of work algorithm
it is very hard to generate the nons and
get the hash value but it is very easy
to verify the transaction by the other
miners so that's whole lot of work what
a Miner's payoff is so for all his or
her hard work they get paid in the
Bitcoins and this is the only way the
Bitcoin get added to the network
sometimes they get other forms of
remuneration as well and this is the
concept of mine training so the entire
process when the miner has done the
proof of work consensus they are
rewarded and this is called as mining so
mining is the process of adding a block
to the blockchain this Miner is the
first person who found a nonce value
that fell within the target requirement
right now for doing this the miner is
rewarded as of today on the Bitcoin
Network a minor is paid 12.5 Bitcoins
for adding a block onto the blockchain
but the reward a miner gets reduced by
half every four years so when the fourth
year will approach for the threshold the
Bitcoin reward will go down to 6.25
Bitcoins and miners also get the sum of
all the transaction fees for that
particular block so the 12.5 Bitcoin
reward is Justified as mining is a very
expensive process it has a heavy toll on
electricity computing power and other
resources on which the miner has tested
now we will take a look at the use cases
where blockchain is applicable in Banks
so we have been incorporating a program
where Banks can validate user identity
and as of now a user needs to do the
process over and over again in each Bank
he has to go and prove the identity in
each bank is there a way we can ease a
process with blockchain and the answer
is yes we can we will be using truffle
ethereum ganache and smart contracts all
of these blockchain technology ecosystem
to make it work and welcome to this demo
for how to build your kyc blockchain
application now I'm gonna show you all
the steps required to deploy your kyc
application what all components are to
be developed and how to go about
deploying and testing your application
so primarily this kyc application will
allow Banks to do a decentralized kyc of
the customers which come to their Banks
so in the demo we will see when a
customer walks into the initiating bank
will do the kyc for a customer enter its
details and verify it and if any
subsequent Bank wants to use the kyc
done by another bank he or she needs to
take the permission of the customer and
then he can use the same kyc for
verification so we will see how can we
do that so just to start off with we
have developed a kyc solidity contract
which has all the necessary functions in
order to do the actions required for
doing a kyc of a particular entity by
the bank now once this contract is ready
we will be placing it in our sample
truffle package so this is my truffle
package and in this I have the contracts
folder in the contracts folder I have
kept my kyc DOT solve file
now in the command prompt I will
compile my contracts
we can ignore the warnings
so here is my ganache client which I
have just started and in my ganache
client as you can see it is running on
Port 8545 and it has already given me 10
accounts pre-funded with 100 ether now I
had already mentioned that my truffle is
connected to localhost 8545 so now when
I'll do my truffle migrate command it
will connect to my ganache and deploy my
kyc contract so now I can go to travel
control and for me it's very important
to see at which particular address my
solidity contract has been deployed I'll
copy it
and in my
UI code under root jscontract details.js
I will make the change of this address
where my contract has now been deployed
now after doing these steps my
application is ready to interact with my
solidity contract which is being
deployed on my local blockchain network
now as you can see when I deployed the
contract this is my primary account from
which the ethers were deducted in order
to deploy the contract now there are
certain steps in order to get the
application up and running so first we
need to sign up the banks
so suppose I say Bank 1 and the password
should be the first address of the bank
so basically we are associating One bank
with one account which we have on our
ethereum Network so we will sign up now
bank one is successfully registered so
how I now in order to login I can check
now bank one I have logged in now I need
to do add a kyc for a particular
customer
now after filling the basic details I
will create the customer and the
username I have kept is customer one
ideally this is the unique identity of
the customer it can be any social
security number or vidhar number or any
unique identity which is attached to the
customer or the email ID and can be used
as the unique identifier for the
customer now once customer profile is
successfully created we need to login as
a customer to allow this bank to see the
kyc details now suppose if I say
customer 1 and search it it is saying
access denied and take the permission
from customer to proceed so before the
bank can do the kyc complete the
customer need to approve it so I am
creating the credentials for the
customer
now customer can see his details
whatever were filled by bank one and he
can see that there is a request from
bank 1 to allow to view his kyc now
before we allow I will also create
another bank bank 2 and Associate it
with my another address
and try to log in with it
now bank 2 is also logged in now bank 2
has not done the original kyc right but
it is trying to look up and its access
is also denied so it needs to explicitly
take permission so the bank will take
explicit requests from the customer
so now the customer has requests from
bank 1 and bank 2 for the kyc it is up
to the customer whether he or she wants
to allow and deny the kyc request after
the permission has been granted then
only the banks can be able to view the
kyc so if I say Bank 1 allow and bank to
deny
now all the requests are done from the
queue so bank one was allowed and bank 2
was denied so if I again login with
Bank One
and the password is my first address
View kyc Customer one
so here it is the bank one is able to
see the details now if I log in as bank
2 and give password and try to see the
it is saying permission denied so let's
ask bank2 to again request
now Bank two is now again a quest thing
and now this time it allows
now bank 2 can see the details so all
these transactions in the back end are
happening on the blockchain network
which is interfacing with the contract
through its subsequent methods now the
primary details of the contract are in
the contract details.javascript where we
have to provide the address at which the
contract was deployed the ABI file the
API so you can get the Avi at here this
is the Avi and you can paste it here and
this is the binary data
which has to be
pasted over here so the binary data can
be fetched
from remix
this is the binary data for the contract
just to be copied and pasted over here
now with these essential inputs provided
our application allows us to interact in
a decentralized fashion to access the
kyc records of a particular customer now
we can modify
the details also
and we can add a new customer again so
this is a basic demo of how a typical
kyc application works in a banking
environment blockchain expert now not
quite yet there's a lot of more
information you need to learn we'll go
to that later now let's do a quick recap
so what have we learned today we learned
what is blockchain the Bitcoin story we
understood the public distributed Ledger
concept hash encryption the proof of
work consensus algorithm the concept of
Mining and the use case of know your
customer blockchain decentralized
application which is used in Banks and
the use case of blockchain in Banks
hello everyone and welcome to this
session of blockchain tutorial part two
my name is saurabh and I'm part of the
simply learn team so let's get started
today and let's see what's in store for
us so hey thanks for coming back to
explain how blockchain work so in our
last session just let's do a quick recap
what we have learned so let let's look
down the memory lane and discover what
we had learned we learned about what
blockchain is so a blockchain is a list
of records with stores data publicly in
a chronological order it applies
security using cryptography it is not
controlled by a centralized Authority
any information on a blockchain network
is accessible to anyone on the network
and as it is a distributed Ledger it's a
shared Ledger everyone has the copy of
the data so these are the primary
attributes of a blockchain also you
learned about Bitcoin and how it works
just to do a quick recap it was
introduced in 2009 by someone or a group
of pseudonymous people known as Satoshi
Nakamoto it aimed to solve the problems
faced by Fiat currencies with the help
of blockchain technology so the
objective was to introduce a new asset
class of cryptocurrencies which can be
used in day-to-day transactions now as
of in 2008 18 there are more than 1600
cryptocurrencies that follow the concept
of Bitcoin and blockchain and are very
popular in our day-to-day lives now
let's talk about the features of
blockchain is the public distributed
Ledger it uses a hashing encryption to
encrypt all the information on the
blockchain it uses proof of work
consensus algorithm for a consensus
mechanism and it works with the concept
of mining in order to reward the miners
for keeping them and maintaining the
sanity of the network and finally about
how you can Implement blockchain in a
banking system so we talked about how to
implement a kyc based blockchain
decentralized app and how it allows you
to create a decentralized banking system
where a kyc done by a One bank can be
leveraged by another bank and the
customer does not have to go through
multiple kyc iterations with each and
every Bank whom he or she wants to
transact with now we will get a little
deeper into blockchain and today we will
talk about these topics we will talk
about what is a candidate block we will
talk about Byzantine fault tolerance
which was one of the earlier consensus
mechanisms then we will talk about the
problem of if we have to add two blocks
at the same time then how does
blockchain handles that then we will
talk about the concept of forking what
are soft folks what are hard folks and
other areas where blockchain is getting
used what is the future of blockchain
and what are the upcoming blockchain
jobs and the profiles which are upcoming
in the market and then in the end we
will do a quick demo on how to create a
smart contract and deploy it for a
particular use case now before a block
can be mined a miner has to make an very
important decision which transactions
would be added to his block so before
transactions are added to the blockchain
they are collected in a temporary
container called a memory pool the
miners select transactions from the
school and they put it in a temporary
block called candidate block so
basically the candidate block is a
temporary block which a miner hopes to
add to a blockchain it's a candidate to
be added to a blockchain so the
candidate block holds transactions that
the miners selects from the memory pool
The Miner then tries to be the first
person to find the nonce value that
satisfy the hash requirements now the
question comes if someone in a
blockchain wanted to input the wrong
data by spreading wrong information
around would he or she be able to get
away with it and that's why we had
something known as Byzantine fault
ronderance so in order to maintain the
sanity of the network and to have the
correct consensus there was something
called as Byzantine fault tolerance
consensus algorithm to understand this
you need to know what the Byzantine
generals problem is so let's imagine a
Byzantine General and three other the
lieutenants need to take over this town
however they are at different places and
can't directly communicate with each
other so here we have the general and
his three lieutenants the general has to
ensure that all lieutenants follow the
same order he or she gives them to
attack or to retreat now this has to be
ensured even if one of the lieutenants
is a traitor so this is the Byzantine
General's problem that how does the
general communicates the correct
decision which he has taken to all his
lieutenants in his Network irrespective
if someone is a traitor in this case a
traitor could ruin the unity of the
group by sending different messages to
different lieutenants now here we can
see that General is giving all his
reference the command to attack the
traitor could ruin this by sending every
other Lieutenant the command to retreat
the opposite now in this situation the
traitor would make others believe that
the General asked them to retreat so as
we can see the lieutenant in brown is
the traitor and he could communicate to
other lieutenants the wrong information
and make them act on his behalf as a
traitor in themselves now this would
cause the lieutenants to retreat and the
General's attack to fail so how do we
tackle this the only way an attack or a
retreat will be successful is by having
a majority supporting that particular
action to achieve this the lieutenant
keep a tally of the orders they receive
so in this scenario the general sends
the attack order to each of his
lieutenants the lieutenants in turn
collect the order they receive and pass
it on to the lieutenant near to them so
each Lieutenant will pass this order to
the nearest left in it the Tracer also
will do the same but hence the retreat
order to the other left lens however
this will not be successful because each
Lieutenant now has a majority of of
attack and minority of retreat so this
shows that the majority of the
lieutenants would follow the General's
command and the attack will be
successful the scenario I mentioned
before is Byzantine fault tolerant now
the same situation can be encountered in
blockchain as well the traitor would add
invalid transactions into the blockchain
the traitor would send the inconsistent
information to other nodes in a
blockchain this would affect the
reliability of blockchain the network
blockchain are able to achieve Byzantine
fault tolerance with the help of proof
of work let's see how it is effective it
is effective because the process of
adding a block to a blockchain is a work
intensive process which involves a
hashing algorithm the process is very
hard very computive because it is
heavily reliant on value obtained from
the existing blockchain to have any
meaningful impact the hacker would have
to take a lot of time resources
producing sufficient proof of work
interesting imagine if you and I were
miners and we both add a block to the
blockchain at the same time how do we
handle such a situation so although this
does not happen very often there is a
way to decide whose block should be
added to the blockchain in an ideal
scenario you just need to be the first
one to find the hash value you need to
be the first Miner to generate that hash
value and win the block so adding two
blocks at the same time the hash value
of the block only needs to be within the
predetermined limit if the generated
hash value is less than the target then
the value is accepted and the block is
added to the blockchain but if it is
greater than the target then the value
is denied and the block is not added to
the blockchain but in this case if two
people have obtained a satisfactory hash
value at the same time so my minor 1 and
minor 2 we are able to find the hash
which was less than the target then what
will happen whether minus one block will
get added to the blockchain or minus 2
block will get added to the blockchain
Now 50 of the network has accepted minus
one block and suppose rest has accepted
minus two blocks so half of the network
continues to work considering minus one
block to be the right block and the
other half Network continues to work
considering -2 block to be the right
block however only one minus blockchain
can be allowed to remain we cannot have
two blockchains running it will defeat
the purpose now this is achieved by
selecting the substance to which miners
have first added a block so suppose
minor 3 adds a new block to minus one
blockchain this block now added by minor
3 is verified by everyone in the network
it is then accepted as the dominant
blockchain and is used by everyone else
is in the network the other version of
the blockchain The Miner 2 is completely
discarded and the entire network now
accepts minor one's blockchain and we
have now a single blockchain existing
now this situation is also called an
accidental Fork so I heard about a
version of Bitcoin called Bitcoin cash
what's the difference between them there
are other kinds too like Bitcoin gold
and Bitcoin private these are all
outcomes of a fork so what is a fork a
fork is said to have taken place when a
blockchain diverges into two potential
Parts a fork happens when the users of a
network cannot come to an agreement with
regards to a Network's transaction
details and the new rules to validate
those transactions so there are two
types of forks which can exist either it
can be a soft work or it can be a hard
Fork a soft Fork occurs when a change in
the Soft C protocol makes new block
added to the blockchain following the
new rules but are Backward Compatible
but in order to have a soft work it
requires a majority of the users to
commit to that change to be successful
so a soft Fork could have multiple uses
it could be for tighter rules it could
be for cosmetic changes addition of new
functions but not affecting the
structure so consider the scenario where
the accepted block size is to be reduced
from 1 MB to 100 KB so first of all it
has to be approved by a majority of the
network now the old version will be
running on 1mb block size but once
approved the new version will start
working on a block size of 100 KB so
anything which is less than 100 KB will
be approved and will be added to the new
block so over time people following the
older version of the blockchain would be
forced to move to the new one since none
of the transactions would go through so
basically people using the old
blockchain they will be using the 1mb
block size their transactions will not
succeed and they will be forced to use
the 100 KV block now let's talk about
hard Fork a hard Fork involves a change
in the software protocol so radical that
it forces a new blockchain to be created
altogether so basically in a hard Fork
there will be two versions there will be
one blockchain that hasn't upgraded and
there will be a blockchain that has
upgraded according to the new software
protocols both these blockchains will be
considered valid and legitimate the New
Path would follow new updated rules
while the other one keeps following the
old path so the old one will not be
discarded and will remain into existence
now Bitcoin performed a hard Fork on 1st
August 2017 which created bitcoin cash
so thereby both Bitcoin and Bitcoin cash
remain existent now Bitcoin cash was
different from regular Bitcoin because
us it increased the block size from 1 MB
to 8 MB so thereby it held reducing the
transaction cost significantly lesser
than that of the original Bitcoin
Network now other than with Bitcoin
where else is blockchain used the other
areas are for preventing voter fraud
blockchain helps in ensuring that there
is only one vote per person ensuring
that the data is not being tampered with
or any false alterations are done it
helps creating an immutable ledger to
record the votes as tallied so once a
transaction or a vote is recorded it
cannot be modified it is also used in
quality assurance ensuring the products
are of highest quality being able to
identify problem areas easily so where
do you think blockchain is going to be
used in the future so blockchain is
seeing wide range of adoption amongst
organizations as of now only one percent
of all organ organizations have begun
using blockchain Technologies but this
percentage is expected to increase in
the next five years or so then there is
a need for blockchain regulations the
rules and regulations surrounding
blockchain are not very clear for
organizations to be comfortable using it
and move towards faster adoption also
there's a need for removing this
negative speculations surrounding
blockchain several Industries fear that
blockchain will disrupt their normal
functioning and believe that the
adoption of a blockchain system is
inward the effort and there is an
increase in job opportunities for
skilled Personnel so as the technology
is maturing there would be a huge
requirement for individuals who can
understand and implement the concepts of
blockchain so what options do people
have for jobs involving blockchain at
the moment there are many job
opportunities but the two most famous
ones are blocked in architect and
blockchain developer blockchain
developer is a profile which requires
designing implementing and supporting a
distributed blockchain Network analyze
user requirements Design Technology
around a certain business model to build
and launch a blockchain network
blockchain architect profile requires to
design and architect blockchain industry
Solutions creates blockchain networks
leveraging blockchain technology
platforms produce high quality code
based on Project requirements
conceptualize design and build
blockchain Frameworks and assets so
let's have a quick demo on how to deploy
a rating smart contract and have
decentralized application running on a
local blockchain network we will be
using truffle and solidity to build this
application so in order to build this
application we should have installed
truffle and ganache on our local system
so this is a ganache client which is
running on my Local Host it is running
on Port 8505 and network ID 57 778
whenever you run a ganache client it is
preceded with 10 accounts and 100 ether
balance now this is my movie rating app
and in this app I am going to deploy a
smart contract called rating dot Soul
which is gono capture the ratings for a
certain set of movies which I'll
pre-define and the users will be able to
set the ratings on a blockchain network
in a decentralized fashion and we will
be able to see that in every transaction
a block is getting generated in my
ganache client so in my movie rating app
under the rating folder I will run the
command trough compile and it will
compile my smart contract rating dot
Soul now the next command which I have
to run is trough migrate
now at this instance the trough migrate
command will deploy my smart contract on
my ganache client so if you see there
are four blocks which have been created
and
my contract was created in this
transaction and this is the address of
the contract at which my contract is
deployed so I can go back to my command
prompt and say trough console and check
the address of my contract so this is
0x695 which is this address now when I
deployed my smart contract I had given
the entry of deployment in a file called
deploycontract.js under rating
migrations and in that I had given this
entry I had given the path to my rating
solidity file and I had initialized my
smart contract with three movies Star
Wars Avatar and Inception and given some
predefined gas now once these steps are
done and I know the address at which my
contract is deployed I will copy that
and paste it
in the file of ethereum setup.js which
is lying under my rating app UI Source
folder and I'll just change this address
now once this rating address is changed
I have to go back to my movie rating app
folder under app UI I have to give the
command npm start
now my application is up and running on
localhost 3000 and as you see I'm able
to do the voting and at each rating
level my block is going to increase
block 6 Inception block 7 and as and
when my rating is increasing a block is
getting added so this demonstrates the
usage of truffle and ganache in order to
build your decentralized app wow
blockchain is amazing thanks for
explaining these things to me I'm glad I
could help you how do you become a
blockchain developer and it's one of the
most frequently asked questions that I
have encountered as well for most of the
people coming from different backgrounds
it's not only from only technical uh for
only people from coming from technical
side but also someone from a very
different industry and they are quite
interested in joining the blockchain
domain in terms of how they can build
something that can change the whole game
of how we do the transactions and these
things so um we are going to discuss a
little bit about
um what could be the kind of steps or
what could be the ways that you can be a
blockchain developer and before going
into the uh discussion of what are the
ways for that first we must need to
understand who is a blockchain developer
itself because there are quite different
terms that being used like some of you
maybe have heard about smart contract
engineer or blockchain engineer or our
blockchain developers so these are
different terms that's being used
interchangeably so along with it you
must need to know the the main
understanding and the terms are being
used and what's the meaning of being a
blockchain developer so moving forward
we are going to discuss a kind of what
could be a type of blockchain developers
on which side you can focus and then you
are going to explore some of the steps
that how you can become and how you can
be planning your journey to become a
blockchain developer as a as your career
so uh we are we'll be moving forward in
in terms of also just exploring a little
bit about the market there was the
salary range that's being provided and I
kind of you can say obstacles uh that is
for someone who wants to learn
blockchain development or who wants to
learn this technology so this is a kind
of our whole agenda that what we will be
discussing in our today's session so
first of all let me first move forward
with the kind of questions that who is a
blockchain developer so initially what I
would say whenever you want to achieve
something or you whenever you you plan
to get yourself into as a part of your
career as a part of your next role first
of all you shouldn't understand some of
the questions and you should ask
yourself a few questions who what and
why you want to be uh to be that
position so uh that's very important
first of all you do try to understand
who you want to be like who who is a
blockchain developer who is a kind of
position that you are looking for then
what are the ways to become that
specific professional in the market and
then why also you should know that why
you are looking forward to be yourself
be a part of this industry or be a part
of this domain that's quite very
important questions that you should ask
yourself not going to answer anyone but
ask yourself and satisfy yourself with
these answers the reason is that that is
going to compose your whole goal or
whole motivation for the uh for your
whole career journey in the terms let's
say if you know that why you are
planning to be a blockchain developer
what is your reason to be in this
industry what is your main motivation
you will be stayed on the whole track
and you can plan these things in a real
way or you can say in a kind of you will
have some timeline that you wanted to
achieve that you wanted to be in this
domain so make sure that you do ask
these three questions before getting
into any XYZ technology it's not just
related to blockchain it's a general
kind of three questions that I usually
make sure that I am clear enough why I'm
going into this direction so that's just
my personal opinion or a kind of my
personal uh belief that I should know
that okay why I want want it to be there
and what could be the ways and who I am
going to be so as a part of this whole
series we are first going to explore the
questions that is who is a blockchain
developer so starting from if you are
just discussing about a blockchain
developer uh it is presumed for sure
that you are well versed with the
technology itself or with the the
working of this technology why it exists
why uh it came into the picture what is
this buzzword everywhere and why this is
booming a lot so as a whole it's being
assumed that you should know what is the
blockchain technology so if you talk
about the technology itself the core
functionality or you can say the core
features of it you are well aware of it
so implementing and designing that whole
blockchain network is something that a
blockchain developer do as well like how
you design a whole network how you
implement and support a network also and
then coming towards creates and
optimizes blockchain protocols and the
very last thing that you go with is how
you develop dapps and smart contract
applications on the blockchain network
it's very important to understand those
terms if we talk about
the dapps DAP is a kind of like
distributed applications that we use
these terms quite often when it comes to
blockchain developer you may have heard
from someone like okay I'm looking for
adapt developer someone who who can
develop adapt for me it's something like
we are talking about applications that
needs to be developed on the top of
blockchain technology and it could be
any blockchain like public or private
any blockchain so that is very important
if you understand these kind of acronyms
and you really know the meanings of
these acronyms that's also very uh
that's something that matters a lot so
dapps is something that you are going to
have those applications built on top of
blockchain and that's one of the part
that blockchain developer do also and
then come towards the next part that how
do you develop these daphs using like
writing some smart contracts using any
programming languages that we'll be
exploring in the in the few slides
afterwards so coming towards like how
you write a smartphone tracks what are
those kind of programming languages that
is needed for you to know and to uh to
be well versed with this so you know the
uh how you're going to make it
technically feasible for your whole
career and and to get your next role so
coming towards
um what could be the type of blockchain
developer you can be because what we
will discuss is a quite a lot of
different things if you notice the very
first part that I mentioned was that how
you can like designing the network
implementing uh and architecting the
solution that's one part of it then we
talked about another aspect of how you
can like um security and optimizing the
whole
um Gap development and then writing the
smart contracts and developing the
applications itself so if it if you
focus on the sides it's being divided
into two kind of two sections one is a
core blockchain developer who actually
works into the underlying blockchain
architecture or you can say working on
the consensus algorithm that how these
things going to be working so that comes
under the core blockchain developer and
then another part that's important is
the blockchain software development or
you can say the app adapt developer who
is going to develop the application
that's being used or that's being built
on top of that blockchain technology so
if we talk about the whole blockchain
development cycle or you can say the
layers is you have one blockchain hosted
on which you are going to develop your
blockchain application
so first you should be clear enough what
kind of blockchain that you are going to
adopt it could be a public blockchain it
could be a private blockchain or maybe a
kind of hybrid somewhere Consortium or
hybrid blockchain and then coming
towards finding the right talent for the
type of blockchain that you are working
on then that's the next part of uh where
software developers or where uh you can
say developers in journal lies into
that's the next part of blockchain
developer is that how you are going to
write the smart contracts or kind of
chain codes and how you're going to make
make those applications work on top of
blockchain so when we talk about first
thing that is core blockchain developer
they are the one who are going to work
on the core features of the blockchain
network itself so if you focus on the on
the category of the blockchain that you
will be selecting let's say if you are
going to go for the public blockchain
for ethereum or archive any application
that you wanted to host on public
blockchain so that's a kind of different
thing you know your consensus you know
everything that's already running into
the network but when it comes to a
private or enterprise-based blockchain
you have a quite different architecture
it's quite bulky it's quite vast like
you have to work around what kind of
network you wanted to build into how
many organizations will going to
participate into the network what will
be the consensus mechanisms that will be
used then how you're going to set up
like let's say if you're talking about
hyper laser fabric you have to architect
the whole thing like participation of
endorsing nodes and Cas and let's say
how it's a whole MSP is going to work
and then the consensus mechanism and how
it is going to be committed to The
Ledger after going through this whole
endorsement policy so there is quite a
lot of network part that needs to be
done in terms of private or our
enterprise-based blockchain which is not
that much required when it comes to any
public blockchain so that core
blockchain developer are the one who is
responsible for working on those side of
how these network is going to be built
into so if you just explore a little bit
about hyperledger fabric Network
Administration that's something a
separate role that's being required for
the organizations who develop on top of
hyperledger fabric it's not that they
expect the programmers to do the whole
networking you know who are architecting
at the base layer but they expect the
the net the network part is something
that they expect someone else who are
expertise who have the required
expertise in that aspect so that where
is the core blockchain developer come
into like when you talk about
architecture or working on this
consensus algorithm and how you're going
to set up the whole blockchain network
that is one part
of the blockchain developer that you can
be now the next part that when it comes
to software development side this is
where the programming comes like how you
are going to develop your application
that is going to work on on the top of
that specific blockchain let's say if I
decided that I wanted to build uh an
application that is going to be on
hosted on onto a public blockchain so
it's a public blockchain application so
I want adapt for that like I want to
build an application so definitely you
don't need to work on to the that
underlying core blockchain layer setting
up the network and these kind of stuff
what we usually do is that we directly
go towards writing our smart contract
logic once we understand the whole
architecture whole flow of our solution
that okay what kind of smart contracts
we are needed at what stage we are
needing that smart contract act and what
is the whole flow of information from
one end to another end and who are the
participating entities and all these
stuff
once you have a very clear idea of that
you go into developing those
applications in terms of writing your
core code core program into the core
programming side then it comes to
writing your smart contracts and first
you are going to use a test Network
let's say so you're going to host it on
a kind of like test Network for ethereum
or then you are going to move into a
main net so that's the kind of things
that's mostly on the side of blockchain
developer that how you are going to
write your code compile it and deploy it
itself onto the blockchain network so
coming towards that what kind of
responsibilities and the usual and the
major responsibilities that needs to be
covered by a blockchain software
developer is smart contracts writing
their smart contracts or you are
required to develop the whole
distributed applications so the reason
of mentioning this develops the
distributed application is that just
writing the smart contracts is not
something you do only you should know
that about when what what will happen
when you are going to deploy your
network and how you're going to check up
all these gas fees and a lot of the
stuff that happened there once you
deploy your smart contract onto the
blockchain network so that's where this
blockchain software development come
into
front and back location so we have a
kind of some middleware
um apis on which we work let's say if we
are talking about uh specifically
ethereum based development we use a
web3.js to interact with our smart
contract and to talk to our front end
also so that is the library that you are
expected to uh write the code and know
that how you are going to interact with
these two layers and act as a middleware
and how you're going to write that
specific kind of HTML code which will
link to your smart contracts easily and
the same thing that follows if you're
talking about any other blockchain let's
say in terms of private blockchain so in
hybridledger fabric when we are
developing an application for that
middle layer specifically we have
different kind of sdks that we use
that's been provided let's say by a
fabric SDK so you you you are bound to
be used like kind of java SDK or node
SDK or any kind of new sdks that being
provided to them let's say part thing is
python is in um in line as well with
them so these are a lot of things that
also involve that how your middleware
will work to talk to a front end for
your blockchain based application that
also comes under under the blockchain
development or kind of how you're going
to work as a software developer or
um or the core technical team for your
blockchain development side
so coming towards that how do you become
a blockchain developer now uh that's
another questions that I am going to
give you a rigid answers on that and
that's something that you should follow
but I believe that as I started in the
earlier um part of our video that you
should know uh answers of these
questions by yourself how you're gonna
do that or what you want it to be and
who you want it to be and what are the
ways to be at this stage so when it
comes to how do you become a blockchain
developer so there are a few things
that's being mentioned here it's it's a
few things I'm mentioning because it
could be more than that it definitely
depends on the type of role that you are
looking into or on the type of
organization that you are planning to uh
planning to like join in or targeting to
be the next employer for them so it's
quite uh you can say quite varied
options that how do you become a
blockchain developer but that's one of
the you can say core answers that
everywhere if you found uh the ways of
being a blockchain developer the very
first part that's very important is the
programming language because as we
discussed
the part of being a software developer
is that you should know a kind of
programming language of writing the code
into the blockchain uh in into this
blockchain whole network
so some of the programming languages
that's being mentioned here it's like
Java C plus plus JavaScript go Python
and c-sharp so as a whole I would say
that is very important for being a
blockchain developer is
you should be well versed about the
basic programming paradigms and
how a whole object-oriented programming
work like the base pillars of object
oriented programming the reason is
that's something quite similar when it
comes to
um those programming languages so if you
talk about any of those programming
languages it's not something that you
are expected to know all of them
definitely no one is not expert in all
of these programming language
but if you are well versed with any one
of them let's say any two of them you
are expected to write your code or
understand the main uh main you can say
um main rules of writing any programming
language because you are already well
versed with any one of or any any two of
them that's very important part that
this is the core of a programming
language that you should know now how it
works into writing a blockchain based
development it's something that you are
going to learn when it comes to any kind
of blockchain development course or any
kind of session that you will be joining
so that's something that you will be
learning as an advanced aspect of it but
the base if you know you are that that's
going to help you a lot in in terms of
your next Journey for the blockchain
development so coming towards uh the
side of writing programming language or
the side of software development on top
of any blockchain application
there is also one programming language
that started with the smart contract so
with the with the existence of ethereum
it's solidity
so solidity developers are something
that they are exclusively expert in
writing this validity uh code or
solidity smart contracts that is being
said because solidity itself is a
contract oriented language okay
but if you just get yourself into or if
you just uh if you just go through a
little bit of how it works or
um a journal view of it you will notice
a lot of thing that is very common and a
lot of Concepts that is very related to
object oriented programming like if you
talk about how you create a class in
object oriented programming language so
that is the same thing that we follow
like how you create a contract in
objective in in solidity itself then we
have few of the uh few of the concepts
that's very much similar to it we have
inheritance in contracts we have
abstract classes interfaces then we have
a kind of aspect that how you
encapsulate things like the
encapsulation aspect of it so a lot of
things how you use a Constructor also so
there are a lot of common things that is
uh very much similar to what you already
know in object-oriented programming
language so for those of you who are a
kind of confident or kind of comfortable
with any of the programming language
that we just just discussed you will be
able to understand solidity very much
easily
one of the different thing that you will
find in solidity is that
how you are going to play around with
with a kind of wallet with a kind of
addresses how it is maintaining uh
connecting to a wallet or maintaining an
address like say smart contract address
itself and then how it's going to hold
some ethers so there are a lot of uh
things or some of the terms or keywords
that is different when it comes to
solidity and obviously it is expected to
be because that is something that makes
it unique
so these are the things that is
different when it comes to solidity
based programming language so if you are
comfortable enough in writing solidity
based code or you can say uh you are
well versed with any of the programming
languages that is in uh oop that's
object oriented programming you will Ace
the solidity side very easily so you can
Smart Start understanding the concepts
and writing those
um contracts and kind of remix IDE that
is a browser-based tool you don't need
to install anything and you can just
start compiling and trying out your
first smart contract very easily by just
installing a kind of like metamask
wallet or something
so there is a very core part of uh
blockchain development side first is the
programming language and then the very
next part that I told you already that
is fundamentals of object-oriented
programming language so we know that how
this is related to a blockchain based
development that how you write a kind of
functions how you get the details for
your users and how you use some
functions to send and receive payments
and let's say how you create a abstract
contract or there's a kind of how you
write some interfaces for your contract
so some very of the concepts that we
already know in object oriented
programming language is quite you can
say similar to what we have in solidity
then we have a kind of flat and
relational databases or you can say that
uh understand the main concept that how
that rdbms work or the flat databases
work in terms of if you know this kind
of file storage or data storage you will
be easily
understanding that how we are talking
about the importance of blockchain
technology itself and how important this
technology itself the reason is that if
you talk about blockchain based
technology as a whole
it's just a kind of uh data structure or
you could say a technology which works
on storing of data that how do you store
data and then the architecture or the
flow of storing the data that is how it
makes it different that how you're going
to store it like either it's in a
distributed Network either it's in a
kind of um you have a ledger that is
decentralized there is no Central
Authority so these are some of the
things if you understand uh the the main
concept of flat relation database you
will be easily understanding these kind
of things about data structures and how
it's being storing this data in terms of
um in terms of blockchain and how it is
unique to any other
databases or any other data structures
also
so one of the major things also that's
written here is that you have to have
some understanding about data structures
like let's say Stacks LinkedIn list
queues so these are some of the um data
structures that we do we have so if you
understand some of them that's very
important that it is linked to
blockchain in the way that blockchain
itself is also a chain of blocks that is
linked together like it's a kind of
linked list and every block is
containing the patch of previous block
so it is changed together so kind of it
is linked together so it is it works in
the same way that we have linked list so
that's one of the reason if you
understand those data structures the the
way how blockchain works at its core of
a data structure it's going to be very
easy for you and you will be able to
understand that how this Works in a kind
of data structure perspective
and then about some of the knowledge of
web development web app development so
that's very um common thing that when
you talk about any kind of development
side so if you know that how
um web and mobile application works and
how you create these applications and
apart from it because the concepts that
let's say if you create a mobile
applications and you have some you want
to expose some apis to get data onto a
mobile application that's something very
much same that we we do in in blockchain
development also so these are some of
the concepts that you are being expected
to know when it comes to becoming a
blockchain development so the very last
part of this um this points that how do
you become a blockchain developer is the
peer-to-peer networking that's something
that I already mentioned in the type of
how you understand the core concept of
blockchain technology in terms of
storing the data and then it comes to
the networking side it's really
important like let's say
those of you who are coming from let's
say
um a very old and very um basics of
computer science you must have heard
about a client server architecture so
what client server architecture do we
have a server to which all the clients
report to for any of the requests for
any of the things whatever being
accepted or whatever being provided by
the server those lines receive and work
on it and and they will be able to
perform uh next steps on it so client
server architecture architecture is
something that is centralized like we
don't have any relation with one client
to another client but all of those
clients are linked to one server or
let's say more than one server but those
servers are the one who is controlling
and who are the managing Authority
but when it comes to a blockchain based
system we don't have that aspect of
centralization
it is a code decentralized Network
that's being also said as peer-to-peer
networking why because all the peers
talk to each other and can see the
transactions whatever others are seeing
also so that's the core part of uh
blockchain development side if you
understand those terms if you understand
that how these things work that is one
of the major thing and then we we talk
about some of the acronyms that's very
important like let's say that is peer
P2P and one of the things that I
mentioned earlier is daps related to
distributed applications that's also
very important and very last third uh
acronym that I wanted to mention is DLT
so what is DLT DLT is a distributed
Ledger technology so if you talk about a
blockchain based uh blockchain based
technology or
you are trying to understand this
technology as a whole
you are expected to know that okay what
is DLT itself because it is a very
important questions most of the uh most
of those who are just newly entered into
this field they know the code they know
the very advanced level of blockchain
but they are not well versed with this
term that said as dld it is a very
important term if you just focus on in
this term is it's an umbrella term like
we have a lot of different Technologies
under DLT
and one of them is blockchain technology
so blockchain is a DLT okay but we have
other technologies that comes under a
DLT as well let's say we have hashgraph
we have
um directed acyclic graph that is dag
then we have
um let's say we have another
technologies that we work into we have
hedera hashgraph and blockchain and many
of those technologies that comes under
DLT it's very important to understand
that the core of DLT is The Ledger is
distributed like it's going to work in a
decentralized way in a peer-to-peer
manner but how it's going to store the
data like the storage of the data it's
different not all of those Technologies
store the data in blocks so it's not all
dlts are blockchain but at its core the
blockchain is a dld itself so that's a
very Broad and umbrella term that you
should know as a as being a potential
blockchain developer make sure that you
are clear enough about these terms and
you are well versed about where and why
you are using these terms
so these are some of the prerequisites
that we discussed that okay how you want
it to be how you do a becoming a
blockchain developer uh what is a
blockchain developer itself I believe at
this stage of this session you are clear
enough about two of this
what you want it to be like what is a
who is a blockchain developer so who is
what you want it to be like what could
be your next role and then how do you
become a blockchain developer so these
are as a whole is just a core steps and
then you can extend your research you
can extend your plan and make your uh
you can say whole journey that how you
wanted to reach a specific goal in terms
of becoming a blockchain developer and
getting yourself into this uh whole
ecosystem
so let's move into the very next step
that's that says the very first step if
we have got all our prerequisites that's
clear we know what we want it to be uh
we know how we are going to be at this
stage so the very first step if you
notice of of this whole system is the
first thing that you understand the
basics of blockchain
so to whoever usually asked me this
question I would say that as a whole
that's very important to to you to
understand and to go backwards to the
point where this technology started
so for the blockchain if we talk about
the very first white paper or you can
say uh one of the white paper that that
started gaining the traction for this
blockchain based technology is Bitcoin
so what you do you go towards this uh
Bitcoin white paper and try to read it
and try to grasp the whole concept
what's being written and why it came to
an existence and how this technology
played an important role in the whole uh
in this whole system that's being
proposed in that white paper
and that stage I wouldn't expect you to
be a master of blockchain technology and
even to be clear of all the terms that's
written there
but after reading that specific white
paper you should be just clear enough
what is this technology what is the
potential of this technology and either
I am interested or not like let's say
either I am convinced with the what this
technology has done uh to this whole
payments ecosystem and everything
if you are a little bit clear enough at
this side you are very good to proceed
further and then what you do you proceed
further with about understanding the
core terms or core concept of blockchain
technology let's say we have uh
different types of blockchains public
blockchain private blockchain then we
have hybrid blockchain so coming towards
understanding the terms if you
understand the base term of blockchain
then you move forward with let's say
public blockchain that is Bitcoin and
after going towards Bitcoin you go and
check in the history the next step and
the next Revolution came into the terms
of ethereum how ethereum came into what
was the reason for that and how it
changed the whole game of this
blockchain ecosystem so there you are
going to explore a lot of thing in terms
of this blockchain based technology the
reason of that is that with ethereum
ecosystem
we had a lot of things that came into
the picture which was not there earlier
we got the way that how you can automate
your business process in terms of those
smart contracts and then using that
smart contracts the scope of this block
blockchain technology extended and it is
being explored that you can use this
technology out of this payment ecosystem
or out of this financial services we
have a lot of uh you can say potential
of using it in different ways or you can
say in different use cases so there come
the the potential and the power of this
this technology
and if you explore a little bit of the
whole journey of ethereum you are going
to uh find a lot of things that's very
interesting the tokenization aspect of
it
um the mining process that how it
changed up to the latest Trend that we
have in now in 2022 so that's very
important part of the whole journey of
of learning these core of this
blockchain based technology and then
come to coming towards the the base
let's say hash uh that how this
cryptographic hash is used how the
system is secured what kind of
encryption that's being used so you can
go through and play around with some of
the you can say demos and illustrations
that's been provided using the how your
data is encrypted how you cannot change
a block and it will break the chain so a
lot of things that you can explore in at
this step and you you know okay there is
some mining that's being provided some
consensus that's happening and the
reason of that consensus also and the
next part of knowing after knowing those
kind of terms is that how you explore
these things let's say ethereum hyper
Ledger hashgraph or Corda artery Coda
that's very important as well and other
solutions that is built on top of layer
one Solutions that's let's say we have
layered a lot of layer 2 Solutions into
the market now but that's another very
extended form of blockchain
so as a base what we do is that you
explore
um starting with Bitcoin white paper
then you move toward ethereum based
blockchain and then you go and explore a
little bit of hyperledger fabric and if
you are at the stage of understanding
hyperledger fabric you can look up into
the R3 quarter as well so a lot of
things you are going to explore in this
whole journey and you will going to
understand the basics of this uh
blockchain itself so if you talk about
this whole steps that we have in this
whole system in this whole systematic
way it is started from prerequisite if
you are done with prerequisites we are
now move towards step one that we have
already done that says the concepts of
blockchain and the very next stage is
that you understand economics behind
cryptocurrencies and blockchain based
technology so that's the part that is
very important you understand the whole
um whole economics in the term of the
usage of blockchain blockchain
Technologies in in crypto world and a
lot of it on the side of how it works in
terms of issuing some kind of tokens and
then we have token standards how you
write these tokens and the important and
the and you can say
um how it it the price is how you're
going to increase your price for tokens
and then we have the next era that we we
know that right now we just passes this
NFP said how nfts came into the market
and what is the best use case of it so a
lot of things you are going to explore
in terms of security
that says uh hashing that is a kind of
hashing algorithm that's being used and
the digital signatures knowing that how
this core this works as a core and then
the consensus mechanism Also let's say
proof of proof of stake why it's being
used or why there is some transaction
that transition that being happened from
proof of work to proof of stake knowing
the benefits and disadvantages for each
of them it's very important also
so that's one of the things that needed
to be uh on the side of
you can say more onto the side of
security or more into the side of
technical aspect of blockchain the other
part is that the economic side
on the economic side we have the
understanding that the miners or you can
say the validators who validate the
transaction are being incentivized so it
is very important for you to understand
that how you are going to be like what's
is there some calculation that's been
happening it's something some halving is
done and after that what's going to
happen if it's finished uh the block
reward is finished so what's going to be
happen with Bitcoin so that's some of
the questions that if you explore that's
going to have some
um you can say some interesting facts
that you will need to explore in this
whole journey
along with it it's very important that
you try to understand about private
blockchain also if you are exploring it
try to go into going to as a whole not
just go through towards public
blockchain and you don't know the
difference between private and public so
if you're talking about private
blockchain you should try to explore a
little bit what happens with the
validators who validate the transaction
in a private blockchain so who is being
rewarded what kind of reward is being
given so you can read out some of the
use cases or some of the success stories
and case studies that's been published
to let's say onto the official website
of hyperledger fabric or Linux
Foundation or official website of
ethereum
ethereum foundation itself so a lot of
things that you are going to find out on
their own official website and for for
further you can say latest up-to-date
Trends and happenings into the industry
you can watch out to some of the videos
let's say and videos and terms that
what's been happening and what's being
announced by their like say co-founders
Founders or any of the speakers who
participated into the conference because
that's also very one of the interesting
part of the conferences if you join that
or if you follow some of the blockchain
latest conferences some of the very
um biggest uh you can say announcements
or biggest
um change that's been happening into the
ecosystem they announce usually there
into the conferences also so you can
follow up to the conference to
understand and to you can say follow the
trends what's happening into the
industry as well so the very next step
that is how to understand how
cryptocurrencies work that is also very
important the reason is that when it
comes to
the blockchain-based ecosystem it
started with the very first use case is
the financial use case is how you can
eliminate a middleman and do some
transaction peer-to-peer let's say Alice
and Bob they don't need anyone in
between and they can do the transactions
without any one of them so that's very
much important to know that if we are
removing the middleman
who is going to do our transaction then
definitely we do have at the core we
have this blockchain based system let's
say blockchain Bitcoin who is going to
do this transaction for us and if you if
you just go backward in terms of the
middleman we are going to have some
validator a miner who is going to mind
the Mind our transaction but things are
a lot of things that are changed when it
comes to peer-to-peer transaction uh
when it compared to the transitional and
a current system of current banking
system or financial system that we have
so that's very important to understand
how this cryptocurrency system work
if you send the money from one account
to another account let's say in terms of
ethers or not only in eaters if you are
trying to do some transactions and uh
you are having let's say some tokens or
something then you will be able to
um do this transaction very quickly and
you will be able to understand it very
quickly how this thing is very different
to the traditional system that we have
so that is also one of the very
important step of this uh four steps or
five steps Journey so you start with uh
the concepts of blockchain based
technology and then you understand the
economics behind it in which you explore
the kind of like security aspect of it
the cryptographic algorithms that's
being used and who will be rewarded and
how the reward will be done and then how
you under then you understand that how
this cryptocurrencies work and the last
thing is that you're getting on some
hands-on experience
and then when it comes to now at this
stage at the fourth stage I believe you
have a clear idea about the technology
you know the strongest strong use case
of this whole technology so far that we
have
you are well versed with the technical
terms that is being used in this whole
uh you can say in this whole technology
or what kind of consensus or encryption
or encryption algorithms or mining why
it's being happening and and the whole
flow okay and if you are clear enough at
this stage you are now able to getting
yourself onto some Hands-On or into some
querying aspect of it so for this kind
of writing some uh programming and some
smart contract you are now able to start
your journey as a blockchain developer
so this stage is very important for a
kind of how you are going to select what
kind of programming languages that you
want to be like what kind of uh
blockchain development you want to be
let's say it's private blockchain public
blockchain and then you will decide that
okay I want to write a smart contract or
I want to write a let's chain code in
hyperledger fabric that's also uh the
choice that you made initially and then
you write your smart contract and you
know that okay if let's say you are
writing it on ethereum based blockchain
you are going to publish it on ethereum
based uh Network so let's say in in
terms of test Network or in terms of
mainnet you can publish it on on the
ethereum based blockchain and then let's
say one of the major thing that's
written into the whole journey what I
appreciate it's not that you do the work
from your end and you expect the things
to happen like magically from from the
employer and or from the end of hiring
you
what is the best way is that if you make
something if you have coded something
even it's a very small application
try to
show off to it to others that what you
have made
by showing off means that you can
convince other that you have the right
talent that is required for this
specific programming language
it could be in any way like it could be
like either you go for having your own
GitHub profile maintain your own GitHub
um whole GitHub portfolio that you can
provide to others so that's the kind of
all your programs that are written you
have all your files that that you can
provide to others just to know that okay
what kind of smart contracts that you
can write
but also you can write some articles out
of it let's say if you are writing a
code in solidity programming language
and you came up with an issue of how
you're going to like you explored some
different ways of error handling like
you have different functions in in
solidity right for error handling and
from your own experience you find out
some amazing way of doing error handling
in solidity that saves some gas fees and
you believe that's a a better solution
out of what you have been already being
provided over the internet
what you can do you can write a complete
whole article on it on the basis of okay
this is my personal finding in my whole
journey I found out this is the best way
and I I I encountered these issues and
to resolve this kind of problems I tried
fixing it in this this way I wrote this
code and that's how it worked
so what will happen others will know
your problem solving skills
your skills of writing a good and solid
smart contract that's very important
so never underestimate the line of code
that you have written or the application
that you have created it might be very
small for you it might be something
that's not convincing for you but for
other or let's say to others that who
are looking up to uh as a as a a
candidate for you as a candidate to you
maybe
it's going to be something that's very
big for them so try posting whatever you
have learned whatever you have made you
can also do some participation in
hackathons let's say you you can
participate and team up with others and
create some uh very you can say
convincing and solid application in a
hackathon that's also going to add on a
lot in your portfolio and that also uh
it's very valuable when it comes to
being this whole blockchain development
Journey so it's not something that I
would say only in in blockchain uh
development Journey but for any of the
development side it's very important
that until you create something you are
not going to learn it in that way so try
getting your hands dirty as early as you
can and then once you are at this stage
that you created a solid application you
can just go and and post it somewhere
and create and maintain your own
portfolio so that you will be able to
portray to others what you have made
okay
and then that is very important again I
would say the whole blockchain ecosystem
or this whole blockchain-based
technology it's evolving very fast so
the developments or the happenings in
this industry it's very quick that you
don't know that when what will happen
so the very important part is that you
keep yourself updated with whatever
being happening it's not about just
keeping yourself updated let's say who
adopted uh hyperledger fabric for their
problem or who which bank adopted R3
core die and they are working on a
solution with partnering with let's say
Swift is now working with
blockchain-based technology it's just
the high level that you should know
but at the core you should be knowing
what's happening inside of this
blockchain industry itself
one of the very common and uh latest
trending news that we had in the in the
past few weeks is the merch that
happened in ethereum from proof of work
to proof of stake and how they merge
this whole layers in the ethereum
ecosystem
so the reason of understanding and
keeping an eye and keeping yourself
updated is that
this technology is evolving very fast
and even the solutions and the startups
that's being built into it it's quite uh
you can say
quite quick you you you cannot expect
anything to happen maybe into the next
few weeks but there is some very uh
amazing happenings or amazing startups
that's being built upon on top of let's
say any Financial ecosystem or or for
any any industry so try to keep yourself
updated and how you do that so it's up
to you you can follow some of the latest
trending articles that's uh that's
publishing some news on blockchain or
you can also
um just find out some of the solid
connections on LinkedIn and get uh get
connected with them follow them in
Twitter so that you know the latest news
what's happening there and that's one of
the reason that's important that you
visit and write some articles visit the
blogs as well and be a part of this
ecosystem
always make sure to put your input to
add your input wherever you feel you can
let's say if today after uh today you
know that okay I wanted to be a
blockchain developer and you are looking
for some of the Articles and you have a
quick thought that okay no this is how
it should be no I believe that this
ecosystem is is like growing so it's
capability something that's very
important or something you can put
whatever you know and whatever your
thoughts into a comment don't ever feel
shy because that's how you are becoming
to a part of this whole ecosystem
now the very important part is what we
will be discussing next because how you
become a blockchain developer we
discussed it and then comes to what kind
of obstacles do you face when it comes
to learning blockchain based technology
so coming towards the part is that how
difficult or easy this programming
language is something that related to
what kind of issues you face okay so
first of all that's very common and I
believe it's most of us face this issue
that the outdated content
let's say if you are working on solidity
based uh programming language and if you
are reading and following an article but
it was written for a very old version of
solidity a compiler version but you have
followed the whole exact program and
your program is not working on that
latest version because maybe something
has changed and they've made it work in
in another way for the latest version
so this is very important the content
that you are following must be
latest it's not a very old content that
you are following or it's not something
that that you can say uh already
outdated okay so that's very one of the
obstacles that we would say into the
solidity or into the blockchain based
journey is that the tutorials you follow
or the content that's been written there
may be the issue is being resolved
already but you are following some
content some tutorial that's very old
and one of the second aspect is very
common again is the lack of quality
content okay so the major thing is that
most of the places where you will see
that okay you will be a blockchain
developer in six weeks in two weeks you
will be a smart uh in four hours videos
a lot of videos that you will be able to
see that it's not that they will not
give you the right content they will
definitely give you but the quality
content is very important and also
after getting this content what you do
afterwards is also very important
so the investment from your side as a
learner or as a as a potential developer
in this field is still there don't just
expect things to happen in a magic way
once you follow a tutorial and you
believe that okay I created this
application now I am a master and I look
forward to the opportunities and I
believe I will be getting hired
somewhere hopefully you will be
definitely but how you can make your
place in the industry is that you try to
create something and then
um make some updations on it let's say
now we have a lot of layer 2 Solutions
also so try to explore many of those
um
Solutions or many of those uh you can
see some of the sdks doesn't that's into
the system or some of the tools that uh
that's now just came into the in this
whole blockchain based development side
so that's also very important for you to
learn from a quality content not from
old content
now that's another very uh you can say
one of the very attractive part of
blockchain based development is the
salary of a blockchain developer so
coming towards the average uh how much a
blockchain developer earns is something
around
um if you talk about in in USD it's
different definitely so it starts from
100K per annum okay it's just starting I
wouldn't say it's it's an average but
it's more of a start
but it definitely depends upon the size
of company that where you are looking
for and where you are aiming to let's
say for a startup it's going to be a
different or a kind of a big
organization is going to offer you a
different rate but when it comes to uh
blockchain based uh development to any
other
um core Tech development let's say
dotnet or c-sharp or even just Java as
well we have a slight difference in the
range that of the salary that's being
provided so the blockchain based
developer or blockchain developer is
usually highly paid
and one of the core reason is not that
the program the technology is booming
only
but also
the supply and demanding
when you talk about the blockchain
ecosystem or blockchain based Developers
the supply itself is like very small and
the demand is like very huge so if we
talk about the demand the demand
outgrows the supply a lot
so demand is growing very rapidly but
the supply of the development or the
supply of the developers is not very
high that's why it's one of the highest
paid when it comes to any of those uh
development side of um into this whole
software development side so which
companies and how companies are using
blocks blockchain based technology again
that's a very common thing that's IBM
Microsoft and they are using in a
different way let's say for trade
finances and we have some countries that
they are using let's say Australia and
Estonia is very famous you can explore a
little bit about estonia's case study
how they have revolutionized their Whole
Health ecosystem the the smart card that
they have for the for the for their uh
citizens or for the residents and then
we have a lot of things that's also
evolved in Dubai also with their smart
Dubai initiative they have gone
paperless uh within a shade of paperless
they buy so a lot of things that's
happening in in different regions it's
not just one or two countries most of
the countries China has also used this
technology in a lot of different ways so
you can explore with how these
Technologies work in different countries
and different companies just to have a
better understanding of the potential of
this technology and if you were
convinced enough that okay
this technology is very uh booming and
the support from the government is very
high then you are
satisfied what you are doing and where
you are investing your time that's very
important and you are motivated enough
you are going on a right track you will
be able to do it very easily and very
happy
so that's a little bit of what we can
discuss in our today session related to
how you can be a blockchain developer
who is a blockchain developer and what
are the steps to becoming a blockchain
developer so this is about our today's
session but we have different courses in
our simply learned uh course as well nor
simply learn training programs that you
can follow and that you can look up to
so you will be able to understand uh
better of what's being provided by
simply learn as for this blockchain
based technology so I wish you all a
very good luck thank you so much for uh
spurring your time for this video in
case of any comments and questions just
feel free to post it on this simply
learn YouTube channel and the team will
be able to get back to you uh on the
queries that's being posted thanks a lot
for joining in we'll back we'll come
back for another video thank you and
with that we have come to the end of
this video on blockchain in-depth
tutorial I hope you found this video
informative and interesting
please feel free to ask any questions
you have concerning the topics covered
in this video in the comments box below
our expert will assist you in addressing
your problems thank you for watching
keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here